اكدت القياده العسكريه مجددا في اخر
محطاتها العمليه السياسيه تتعثر
انها ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري التي
عقدت لاربعه ايام متتاليه قدمت فيها اوراق
تناقش التفاصيل الفنيه لهذه العمليه التي
يرى البعض انها معقده
التعقيد الذي تجلت صورته هنا بالقاع التي
احتضنت ختاما غاب عنه ممثل الجيش والشرطه
وجهاز المخابرات العامه وحضر ممثل قوات
الدعم السريع بحيث ان الامور كانت تسير
بطريقه ممتازه وصبيحه هذا اليوم كان يفترض
نجلس ايضا حتى نناقش
المناجيز التوصيات التي تقدم بها الاخوه
العسكريون وفوجئنا انه المساله تاجلت جهاز
النساء
وخرجنا بما خرجنا به قبل قليل
ورغم المخاض العسير لهذه العمليه والمخاطر
التي تتهددها يظل الامل قائما لانهاء حاله
الاحباط التي سيطرت على الكثيرين ممن
حضروا هذه الجلسه في السبب يخلي الجيش ما
يكون موجود في الجلسه الختاميه لانه انا
ما بعرف الحصل شنو في اللحظات الاخيره لكن
ده ما بيخليني انه انا اكون عندي يعني
معكم متفائله بانه حيحصل لقدام خير وانه
الاتفاق الاطاري حيمشي لمراميه
يصل للهدف بتاعه النهائي
القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي ترى
ان اللجان الفنيه ستواصل عملها لاستكمال
وصياغه التوصيات النهائيه التي تشكل عقبه
تسعى الاطراف لتجاوزها هذا وسط اوافق
اللجاره المتخصصه منا العسكريين والمدنيين
النقاشات حول الصيغات الفنيه والعامه
النهائيه للتوصيات التفصيليه لورشه العمل
بغيت نشرها للراي العام وادراجها في مسوده
الاتفاق السياسي
الجلسه التي انعقدت بغياب الاطراف
الاساسيه وهما الجيش والدعم السريع اكدت
ان الخلافه بينهما اكبر من نقاط الاتفاق
ورشه الاصلاح الامني اختتمت اعمالها بلا
توصيات الامر الذي يعقد بالوصول لاتفاق
النهائي سالم الهاشمي العربي الخرطوم